- I was just messin' with this kid
who's number one fuckin' guy in the world.
I was like, you can just DM Dave East,
he's like, yo, that's
my fuckin' favorite guy!
I was like, that's what's up.
Yeah!
You got your perspective.
(crowd cheers)
I just want to be heard.
(upbeat music)
Good, that's it, how are you?
That call brought people value, man.
- [Jeff] Right, it's like I
try not to like worry about it
because it's like damn I've
got GaryVee motivating me
but then I've got my mom
telling me to go back to school,
like, I'm just in the middle so much
- Your mom's wrong I'm right.
Get your Mom on the phone,
let me talk to your mom.
- [Jeff] Nah she's not with
me right not, I'm on vacation.
- What are you on vacation for, man?
Do me a favor e-mail Gary@vanermedia,
You're coming here, you're
spending one day here,
you're coming here, you're
coming to Vayner Media one day,
I'm gonna put you with a crew,
I need to get you re-wired.
How old are you again?
- 21
- Yeah I mean,
honestly, you've got to do
me a huge favor, my man.
Like the serendipity of
us being here together,
you need to realize how lucky
you are for being this young.
Like all that pressure we
talked about on the call.
Like, I know your mom
wants you to do this,
I'm sure you're seeing
everybody else do that.
Dude, you're gonna live another 21 years,
your whole life, and you'd
still be younger than me.
That's real, and once you
wrap your head around that
shit can get so good.
Is there anything you love
to do because I really,
you know how people talk
about do what you love
and everyone's like, yeah
whatever, what the fuck,
how am I gonna make money?
The reality is the with
the way the internet is
its getting weird, not that its so easy,
but like, when people are
like, I can't find my passion
or I can't do it a lot, I'm always like,
well, what do you like?
Like to me, I wish more people realized
that if they love video games
and they can play 15 hours a day,
then you can either become a
esports player, that's hard,
that's like getting into the league.
But you could start a fucking
Instagram, podcast, and YouTube around it.
- And that's what happened with me
and the crazy thing is back in 2011
I was deep into the gaming community
but it's just, I was just like--
- I can't make money in that.
- Yeah I couldn't make money.
- That's what happened, man.
- Or I was just like you know.
- You know, that's what always happens,
cant' make money in rock and roll,
can't make money in hip hop,
can't make money in video games,
can't make, and then you can.
- Right.
- That's the biggest advice I give kids
is like if you're 16 right
now, and you love something
and everybody tells you
there's no money in it
that's 'cause there's
no money in it today.
There might be money in it in 10 years.
Is there anything I can help you with?
- Honestly, I just want to know how can I
just make sure I'm being
solid with myself, that's it,
'cause like I'm trying
to be an aspiring artist.
- Music?
- Yeah, music and so, but with me is
I don't have all the tools yet.
so I'm trying to work everyday, like.
- Are you a producer, are you an artist?
- Artist.
- And you've heard this from
me, I would literally fuckin'
DM every fuckin' music
producer in Manhattan
and be like, yo, I got 15
hours for you for free.
If Ill Mind gives you 15 hours
for you to get his coffee and do shit.
If he just says yes 'cause
on that, I mean, look,
what the fuck are you doing here?
I said yes for no fucking
reason, I do a lot of calls.
- Right, that's what I'm saying.
- People don't get it,
like just like one yes.
If you wanna be fuckin'
in the music business
hit up everybody in the music
business in New York and,
when you have nothing to give
you have your time to give.
My big thing is, but if
you love music so much
isn't that a good use of 15 hours?
Imagine being in a studio
learning how to produce
and Dave East is in the booth,
you'd be like that's fresh.
- Yeah, that's my guy, that's
crazy that you said that.
- Right, so you'd be like this is fresh.
I assume it doesn't
feel like work for you.
- It's what you love, you love--
- Now it's what you get to
do, right, it's steps, right,
you gotta do this eight til midnight.
Right, and your mom's
saying, get a real job.
And its real shit, his
are very similar, like.
Everybody's got the same shit.
There's somebody that they love,
by the way, it could be your girlfriend,
your boyfriend, your grandmother,
somebody who sees the world different
and thinks people should do something
that they think is right.
- And that's the thing that's
the problem because like,
I want to do this but it's
just like I'm hearing,
go to school or take a
trade, and I'm just like,
I wanna make music so I can inspire.
- Do that at 30.
21, you should be taking
risk around your happiness.
You can get a real job at 30
and still be a fucking kid.
- That's the number one
thing too, I was just like,
if anything, man, I want to
work with Dave East if anything.
If anything, 'cause that's
the only person I feel like
that's real with the whole music industry
and how he operates is like.
- So you should DM Dave
East and be like, yo,
I will work 10 hours a
week for you for free.
Pick up your fucking
clothes, I don't give a fuck.
I want to break into the music business
and I know the number
one thing that I have
to give you is my blood.
- But like, that's what
I'm saying, how do I like?
- You go on Instagram, you
go to Dave East's account,
and you DM him.
- I don't know man, I
don't like to be annoying.
- You don't ask, you don't get.
And when you're hitting
somebody up, right,
when you're hitting somebody up to,
when you're hitting somebody
up to fuckin' give them value
then you're giving value, right?
Like, it's not like you're
asking for something,
you're trying to give value, you know.
Like, that's how I see it.
Like, that's just how I see it.
You're not annoying if you're like,
yo, I will give you 10 hours of my time.
DRock hit me up four
times and was like, yo,
I will make a free video for you
and on the fucking, you know,
on the fourth time I said yes.
And you never know when
yesterday his assistant quit.
- Right.
- Bro, you're sitting in this room
on fucking putting your phone
number into an Instagram Live,
then we had a pic the
fucking phone number,
call you, have a conversation
that compelled me to invite you here.
You're sitting here 'cause
I know how many people
are feeling the exact same way
and you and I combined can help somebody.
But I wanted to start with you
'cause you're here, it's real life.
Listen, you should come through again.
I gotta go to my next shit,
you should come through again.
Listen to me, start by just
fucking giving people free time.
People that you want to be close to.
I mean, it's funny that we
just randomly picked Dave East
but like, he's the best,
he's a good kid too.
Hit him up, DM him.
- I was trying to get him,
yeah, that would've been great.
- My boy.
- What up, family.
I was just messing with this kid
who's number one fuckin' guy
in the world, say what's up.
- Yo, Dave East, what's good?
- What up, bro.
- I was telling this kid, I was like, yo,
like, if you want to
get into the music game
just DM the person you love the most
and just offer fuckin' value.
I was like, you can just DM Dave East,
he's like, yo, that's
my fuckin' favorite guy!
I was like, that's what's up.
Yo, I'm looking forward to this week.
- [Dave] Hell yeah, can't wait, bro.
- You been good?
- Yeah, hell yeah.
- All right man, I'm running
for this next meeting,
I'll catch up with you
later, you in New York?
- Yeah, I'm here.
- Until what, Friday or
Thursday or whatever, Friday?
- Yeah, til the weekend.
- All right, I might hit you.
- All right.
- All right, man.
Whether it's Dave East or
Diddy or fucking 2 Chainz,
if you hit up people you want to fuck with
and just like, yo, I'm hungry,
I got 10 hours for you,
I'll come in and build a crate,
I'll fuckin, like, you understand?
- And one yes could be,
- That's all you need is one yes.
- That's what I'm sayin', like,
with people like Dave East,
like, how do work with them, like, do you?
- You give them what they want.
Like you don't have anything to give yet
other than grunt, your hours.
But interns become CEOs all the time.
Learn the game, you know?
All right, let's do it.
(upbeat music)
Tell me everything, I mean,
obviously I know a lot
from just living and life but
gimme the state of the union of the crew
and like what you guys are up
to and like how I can help.
- Well, I'm gettin' into the internet now.
I got out, when I got out of prison.
- And when was that, exactly?
- '09.
- Okay, after how long?
- 20 years.
I found out about you about
four months ago, you know,
because I wasn't, I
don't watch TV, I don't--
- Trust me, I'm thrilled anybody
knows who I am so I get it.
By the way, I'm the same
way, I'm in such a cocoon,
there's so much shit that.
- Yeah, and then when I heard you--
- The world is so fragmented now
and you could be the biggest rapper,
the biggest kid on Tik-Tok,
I mean, athlete, like,
the world's so, it's not 1984 anymore
where everybody knew the same people.
- Right.
And then after I started to
hear you speak and I was like,
fuck, this guy says--
- What I'm thinking.
- The way I think, the
way I ran my drug empire,
the way that I do everything
right now, this guy does it.
And I started telling Sam, one of my guys,
that I would like to meet this guy,
you know, I would like to
sit down and talk to him.
- I'm glad we're here.
- [Sam] At the beginning of
the year I was like, Rick.
- He's the one that introduced me to you.
- [Sam] Last year I was like, Rick,
you gotta check out GaryVee,
'cause someone put me onto
you and I was like, yeah,
so I showed him the video and he was like,
this guy thinks just like
me, he thinks just like me,
and like at the beginning
of this year I was like,
Rick, I'm gonna have you meet GaryVee.
- I'm glad you made it happen,
I'm glad we made it happen.
- [Sam] You guys have the same
wavelength, you guys preach.
- Listen, I am so on the record on like,
this is all the same
shit, I just believe it.
It makes so much sense to me,
I don't have every T and
I crossed of your career
but anybody that's successful
in flipping and organizing anything,
whether it's garage selling,
drugs, sneakers, business,
it's the same mechanics,
and, I'll be honest with you,
the internet actually is creating a system
that leans more towards
like, I'm a street kid,
I was a D and F student, I
didn't sell drugs but like,
baseball cards or, it's all the same shit
and the internet's making it more valuable
for us non students than the students
and so I actually think
the greatest generation
of what has historically
been the have nots is coming
because this equalizes everything
and then what takes over
is the way you and I think.
Because now you're going into
intuition, human behavior,
we're this close to being psychologists.
(laughs)
It's true.
(upbeat music)
Trav, I wanna, can I taste the wine?
I literally have not tasted the rose yet.
Fuckin', the alumni
program's here, like this is.
- [Travis] I wanted to bring in vikings.
- I know, fuckin', the alumni's here,
it's fuckin', it's a party.
What's up brother, how are
you, it's great to see you.
- Should I pull this up?
- Yeah, pull it in.
Dude, I'm so excited right now.
- [Colleague] Have you tried it?
- No, this is literally the
first time having the wine.
I blended it and we birthed it
but I haven't seen my child yet.
All right, this is literally me tasting
Empathy Rose for the
first time ever, ever.
Let's go.
Good nose.
Handsome them up, this.
We're in deep shit, I'm kidding.
(laughs)
We really nailed it, I'm like,
that's why everyone likes it.
So, here you are, you've been
successful by all accounts.
I personally believe that you're about
to get really successful
because I think you're patient and hungry
and doing the right things
and even if the global
economy takes a step back,
I just, I can see it.
I know exactly who you're gonna be at 71
and I'm looking forward to
having war stories with you.
But you're sitting here
and telling everybody
the 72 hours I spent
with this person shaped,
you know, you had your natural DNA,
the hustler immigrant shit, fine,
I just wish more people heard you
and this is why I'm making
the big to do here, 72 hours.
Now, all of you who I tell in your 20s
when you're doing dick shit
nothing with your fuckin' life,
when I tell you to spend two
hours a day on your couch
doing dick shit nothing
and DM everybody you admire
and say to them, I've got fucking time,
you're busy as shit, I
will fuckin' do anything,
eat shit for 15 hours a
week for free for you,
once in a blue moon somebody says yes
and that will change your life.
Happened to you, happened to DRock,
like, happened to Andy, this is real.
Thank you guys for watching,
hope you guys are super well,
hope you enjoyed it, hope
that was a really good one.
That was a real good one.
- I'm here for you, brother.
- I appreciate that.
- You enjoy this for your work outs.
- I appreciate it, brother.
♪ I pray for the worst to go ♪
- We're at Made in New York Pizza
with a little bit of a meet up,
we hit up a bunch of influencers,
new location, I'm an investor
in Eytan Sugarman's place
'cause dude, I'm excited
to see a bunch of people
that I haven't met who
follow me on the Gram,
bunch of good pizza, say
what's up, hello, hi,
that's where we're at.
Jeffrey, what's up, baby?
Takin' full advantage of the
day, full advantage, baby.
- Yo, Gary, that pepperoni though.
- This is place is crazy.
- I never seen someone put
so much pepperoni on a slice.
- It's true, it's like, it's like,
the pizza's the actual topping,
it's like pepperoni with some
pizza, it's true, it's true.
Look at DRock in the back.
DRock, you servin'?
- DRock is rockin' back there.
- He's makin' content.
- [Monica] Basically what
I was saying to him is that
I understand the mindset
has been so popular,
everyone on Instagram
is growing the mindset,
and I know you touch on
this a lot with your empathy
but it's like really
understanding the heartset
and my question to you is,
when do you think people are gonna start
really taking seriously like
listening to your heart,
meditating, what's happening through--
- When the next cycle of pain.
I think most of the shit that I'm spitting
gets really understood the
next time we have economic pain
because even right now
I'm starting to feel
public backlash a little bit,
that I'm spitting a
little too much happiness.
And people are shitting on
me a little bit about like,
no no, you need to make money.
I'm like, cool, that's fine right now
'cause the economy's great,
hit me up when shit hits the
fan and everybody's in trouble.
So I think a lot of
this will get cleaned up
and synthesized when
the fucking shit hits--
- [Monica] People have hit rock bottom.
- When the economy gets tough
brands don't have money
to give influencers money.
Now what?
People are naive because they're young
and haven't lived through a cycle.
Even you at 34, you just went through it
but you were so young, like, you know,
you haven't lived it, you
haven't lived when like
the market collapses.
What I'm most worried about
is people played up something
that they may have to take a
step back and it's gonna hurt
more than they're willing to feel the hurt
and I don't know what they're gonna do.
The biggest mistake influencers make
is they pander to the platform
not to their own happiness.
You know what is gonna work and get likes
and you'll do that over what
you actually care about.
- Yeah, I know, I'm just--
- Well, fuckin' don't do that.
- [Arika] I actually keep like
going to hype stuff or cool stuff--
- [Gary] The number one
mistake that influencers make
is they pander to the platform,
not to their happiness,
it is the number one mistake.
Post abouts something
that fuckin' makes you--
- And then that's how we get depressed,
that how we get depressed
'cause we try to be cool
or try to go to every event.
- Or you put out something
that you know gets 10,000 likes
instead of something
that's gonna be meaningful to your life.
- But I mean, we just wanna
get the fire photo out.
- Don't, it's not making you happy enough.
- It's not.
- The end.
But you have to post shit
that makes you happy,
not what you think is
gonna get good engagement.
Because then you become fuckin'
sucked up in the machine.
- I did, for 11 years.
- No shit.
You can't let that happen.
- [Arika] I'm part of the machine.
I wasn't at first, I was--
- That's how the fuckin' machine works.
- I know, now I'm like--
- Be smart.
Otherwise it's just gonna
get worse and worse.
- To be the Ryan Seacrest of sports,
that's my goal, that's my dream,
I'm already working on it.
- I have a real thought about that.
I think what you should do
is disproportionately try
to bring people value.
So like, I don't think people understand
how much leverage there is in giving.
So figure out who the 500
most important people are in sports,
whether it's the people
that run, whether it's,
do you know Erika the CEO of Barstool?
- I haven't met her yet, but my agent--
- Send me an email right now.
Here's the thing, Jackie,
that everybody fucks up,
so you go and meet Erika and what happens?
Everybody's in the mindset of like,
Erika, what can you do for me, right?
How do you, Erika, as the CEO of Barstool
help me become the Ryan
Seacrest of sports.
What you need to figure
out is, hey, Erika,
the fuck can I do for you?
- [Jackie] Here's how I can help you.
- Nope.
- No?
Wrong, wrong.
- No, no no.
The worst thing to do is
what can you do for me,
the next worse thing is,
here's how I can help you
'cause that's you giving on your terms.
The best thing you can do is,
hey, Erika, let me listen to
you, what can I do for you?
Got it?
- I get that, I get that.
- Pepperonis are legit, have you had one?
- What about you, bro?
- Sup, man, appreciate it.
- Yeah, thanks for coming.
- I'm the finance team.
- I know who you are,
I see you fuckin' almost,
you're one of the few people
I walk with 'cause I go to
the bathroom, I see, we good?
- But yeah, I'm also on another team so.
- Yeah, I'm aware.
- Yeah man, all good, I appreciate it.
Is it cool if I grab a quick photo?
- Of course!
All right, Jas, this is it,
I got no fucking closing,
I'm fucking finished, good
day, got a lot of shit done,
you got what you fuckin' needed,
eat some fuckin' pizza, see ya.
(upbeat music)